[Música]
hola bienvenidos al debate de france 24
soy santiago lópez gonzález gabriel
boric se asumió como nuevo presidente de
chile en medio de mucha expectativa por
el rumbo que puede tomar este país
austral su agenda comienza con una lista
de prioridades muy amplia como por
ejemplo el proceso constituyente la
crisis migratoria seguir haciendo frente
a la pandemia del cob y 19 e impulsar la
economía del país así como la renovación
del sistema de pensiones y también
avanzar en una agenda particularmente
feminista y enfocada también en el medio
ambiente pero tal vez el reto más grande
del presidente boris es su propuesta de
implementar un sistema de bienestar que
tenga la capacidad de reducir las
desigualdades que llevaron precisamente
al descontento de varios sectores de la
sociedad chilena y que llevó luego al
llamado estallido social para analizar
este tema saludamos a lucía miranda ella
es docente en la universidad católica
silva henríquez en la ciudad de santiago
ella se encuentra allí en la capital
chilena también hemos invitado a isabel
castillo ella es doctora en ciencia
política investigadora
en la escuela de gobierno de la
universidad católica de chile y del
centro de estudios de conflicto y
cohesión social ustedes también nuestros
televidentes pueden participar en este
debate en este análisis pueden dejar sus
comentarios y sus preguntas a través de
las redes sociales de france 24 no se
encuentran en facebook también en
instagram y en twitter estamos como
france24 y un bajo e s santi logo que es
mi cuenta personal les recuerdo que la
etiqueta es numeral el debate efe 24
esperamos por supuesto todos sus
comentarios y sus preguntas en torno a
este análisis comienzo inmediatamente oí
una intro muy corta porque el tema es
bastante extenso hay muchos temas para
analizar en torno a este inicio de
gobierno allí en chile- comienzo con
lucia entonces allí en la ciudad de
santiago
preguntándole por el sentir que hay por
lo menos en la comunidad internacional y
es que hay una especie de cambio de era
o tal vez un inicio de un nuevo capítulo
en la historia política de chile con la
llegada de gabriel boric a la
presidencia de este país suramericano
cuál es su opinión lucía bienvenida
gracias muy buenas noches de todas
maneras tanto la campaña como la toma de
posesión del presidente boris estuvo
cargada de simbolismo pero que no son
sólo simbolismos es decir en las
sociedades nos hemos parado a que el
predominio de los hombres se ve como
algo normal en los cargos de
representación y en los cargos de toma
de decisiones
transversalmente y el esfuerzo
específicamente que hizo en el proceso
de toma de posesión es de que casi todos
los cargos fueran paritarios y hasta
cargos que tradicionalmente se habían
habían sido asumidas por hombres como la
edecán que es la primera vez de camps
mujer quien la policía que manejaba el
coche etcétera son simbolismos pero digo
que no son solamente simbolismos porque
tienen un efecto práctico es decir que
nos acostumbremos a entender que los
puestos de toma de decisiones que los
puestos de gestión que los puestos de
seguridad están compartidos tanto por
hombres como por mujeres efectivamente
es una nueva forma de presentar de hacer
política ya hemos visto algunas
reacciones sobre todo de miembros de la
centroderecha que durante el proceso de
la segunda vuelta quedaron a la deriva
forma las decisiones tomadas desde una
perspectiva de política tradicional
quien no ha sabido con esto quiero decir
la derecha le ha costado mucho adaptarse
a este nuevo ritmo de una a un lenguaje
cercano y demás es decir de esta nueva
forma de comunicar y hacer política y
ahora por contra mola y sabe el castillo
también allí en la ciudad de santiago
que piensa al respecto este sentir que
por lo menos es lo que se percibe fuera
de las fronteras chilenas un nuevo
capítulo de la historia política del
país un cambio de era un nuevo enfoque a
nivel político para este país
suramericano bienvenida al programa
muchas gracias por la invitación
sí bueno creo que hay varios aspectos en
los que el gobierno que se está
iniciando marca un cambio de era de
partida desde la transición en el año 90
este es el primer gobierno que no es
parte de ninguna de las dos coaliciones
principales que se conocían como la
centroizquierda y la centroderecha
y entonces en ese sentido ya rompe un
poco con la tradición política de las
últimas tres décadas hay también cosas
evidentes en un cambio generacional en
la acaba de cumplir 36 años en su
gabinete hay cierta mezcla generacional
pero hay un predominio en el núcleo más
cercano de
personas de su generación que tienen que
vienen esencialmente de los movimientos
sociales entonces tienen un origen algo
distinto de lo que veníamos
acostumbrados que eran políticos más
asociados a movimientos sociales lo que
lucía mencionaba también del movimiento
feminista se debe recoger mucho de la
movilización o de los movimientos
sociales que han estallado fuertemente
en chile en los últimos años y además
esto estamos en medio de un proceso
constituyente que no sabemos
exactamente en qué va a derivar pero hay
y eso también puede marcar un cambio en
el inicio de una nueva etapa que
evidentemente tomará muchos años en
tomar forma no es algo que ocurra de la
noche a la mañana pero chile está en esa
búsqueda de recomponer la relación entre
la política y la sociedad de buscar un
nuevo modelo de desarrollo un modelo más
inclusivo
en todo sentido en términos de género de
los pueblos originarios de y ciertamente
en términos redistributivos y
socioeconómicos exactamente isabel lucía
históricamente el contexto es muy
particular para este nuevo presidente
que llega a asumir allí el liderazgo de
este país allí en el palacio de la
moneda en santiago hago la ronda a la
inversa isabel quiero preguntarle
rápidamente muy puntual por favor qué
significa entonces para la historia
política de chile para estos poco más de
tres décadas de democracia
tras el fin de la dictadura
y que este gobierno deje completamente
de lado esos dos bloques que usted
mencionaba de la centroizquierda y la
centroderecha que son los que se han
disputado el poder tradicionalmente allí
en chile- que significa entonces esta
ruptura política
bueno creo que es una señal de una forma
de hacer política que es algo todo y es
y estos partidos tradicionales se
desconectaron mucho de la sociedad y en
general han perdido legitimidad
pero tampoco la ruptura no es total la
coalición inicial de gabriel boric
es pequeña y por en parte por necesidad
creo que también aporta algo de
convicción en la segunda vuelta y ahora
también en el gabinete esta coalición se
amplió no incluye como un actor
importante al partido socialista que es
un partido el partido de la ex
presidenta michelle bachelet de ricardo
lagos que participó en todos los
gobiernos de la concertación entonces
hay este nuevo impulso pero tiene
también vínculos con con este partido
histórico entonces hay ahí también una
cierta una suerte de transición y lúcida
a sus impresiones sobre este tema sobre
la ruptura
digámoslo así así lo estoy mencionando
pero si usted lo quiere calificar de
otra manera bienvenido el concepto que
quiera traer a la mesa y pasó con usted
para darle más adelante sobre las
expectativas que hay pero comencemos por
esa ruptura
mira la verdad si coincide con con
isabel en esto que decía de qué se trata
más bien de un recambio generacional
porque pensemos que el grupo de gabriel
boric camila vallejo y giorgio jackson
comenzaron las movilizaciones en 2011
movilizaciones en este momento por
reforma estudiantil con una clara
demanda de avanzar en los cambios que la
concertación no había hecho a lo largo
de las décadas de gobierno y en ese
sentido efectivamente la concertación se
vio por una parte siendo el grupo más
social pero que se terminó están canto
le llamaron también que se han
identificado también como que habían
caído en la política de los acuerdos es
decir que por un consenso una
estabilidad
inconsistente se habían sostenido
acuerdos que no permitirán un cambio y
el discurso de boris en su campaña ha
sido ampliamente por avanzar en el
cambio no hablaría de ruptura sino de
recambio o no hablaría de avance de
progreso
efectivamente la derecha así ha caído en
una fractura y la derecha la que está
quebrado por una debilidad de
convicciones a la hora de decidir apoyar
un candidato de extrema derecha en lugar
de mantenerse firme con la
reivindicación de la democracia ese
quiebre que se dio dentro de la derecha
sí vaticina una reconfiguración del mapa
político donde en este momento de alguna
manera a la derecha está lamiéndose las
heridas viendo la centroderecha sobre
todo porque de alguna manera la extrema
derecha
salió de alguna forma con unos niveles
de apoyo importantes pero la
centroderecha que es la que más ha
tendido a ganar apoyos tiene que
reivindicar un mensaje más liberal para
poder reconquistar un sector del
electorado entonces en este sentido
hablaría de ruptura en este sector de
representación y en el caso de la
izquierda aquí de un recambio una
renovación importante este punto lucia
recoge el concepto que usted trae a la
mesa debate cambio avance precisamente
este cambio este avance que es uno de
los síntomas que viene presentando la
sociedad chilena como una necesidad
imperiosa allí en este país
llevó al estallido social a las
multitudinarias manifestaciones en plaza
italia en el centro de santiago y eso ha
generado muchísima expectativa en torno
a el plan que va a desarrollar el
presidente boris ustedes que están allí
en santiago se siente esa enorme presión
esa expectativa el mismo presidente ya
hizo un llamado y dijo por favor bajemos
un poco los ánimos bajemos las
expectativas esto no es tan sencillo
como uno cree ya cuando se empezó a
enfrentar los primeros días las primeras
horas de mandato lucía
y efectivamente en teoría en su discurso
de toma de posesión frente a la
ciudadanía y en la moneda dijo vamos
lento porque vamos lejos haciendo una
invitación a bajar un poquito la
adrenalina pero efectivamente bueno
isabel ahí tendrán datos más frescos
porque ella es parte del coes y ahí hay
un seguimiento un recuento de cómo han
progresado las protestas en chile
efectivamente la crecida en el nivel de
protestas en chile está íntimamente
relacionada con la con la
poca respuesta a estas demandas sociales
que fueron bueno movimiento estudiantil
este se ha mantenido de forma permanente
el tema medioambiental el tema de las
pensiones pensemos que chile es un país
donde las pensiones son completamente
privadas no hay una opción estatal
y se han demostrado niveles de colusión
entre quienes ostentan digamos el ahorro
de esas pensiones que no digamos no
devuelven a quien ha aportado durante
todos sus años de trabajo el dinero que
le correspondería y otros temas más
también a la salud etcétera entonces ese
aumento en las protestas ha hecho un
casi una olla a presión de demanda que
efectivamente no van a poder ser
saldadas en una sola administración
política y tampoco quizás con el mismo
orden la nueva constitución va a
requerir un proceso de adaptación y
demás entonces el vamos despacio porque
vamos lejos es clave para que no se vea
atosigada esta residencia isabel
relacionado con esta pregunta sobre las
expectativas que tan
pacientes pueden ser los chilenos con el
desarrollo de este plan
mencionan las protestas cómo fueron
evolucionando lo lo decía lucía en su
intervención los chilenos podrán
entender tener esta paciencia para
comprender que el cambio que requiere el
país y lo que ellos están pidiendo
tal vez boliche no lo vaya a completar
en su mandato y que esto requiera muchos
años más hay paciencia por parte de la
ciudadanía ya están empezando a sentirse
presiones por parte de diferentes
sectores para hacer cambios rápido
bueno es complejo el tema de el manejo
expectativas como comentaba lucía el
presidente y su entorno han enfatizado
que el curso de
de convicción profunda con los cambios
pero de de hacerlo con tiempos de
un contexto económico que es complejo y
una serie de condiciones que dificultan
avanzar yo diría yo creo que él
hay una mayoría pero mucha gente
entiende que estas cosas no ocurren de
la noche a la mañana y entiende también
que el proceso constituyente o la
implementación de una nueva constitución
va a tomar tiempo yo creo que lo
importante es que se vean al menos
algunos cambios incluso ya dentro de lo
que hay no dentro de mejorar la
implementación
o la calidad de servicios que ya existen
sin necesariamente es reformarlo el gran
tal vez si no interrelaciones que van a
ser los sectores más movilizados que son
los que podrían
lanzarse a la calle y desestabilizar un
poco más el gobierno más que el
ciudadano
y el ciudadano común y corriente si se
quiere no hay esos sectores tienen
cierta desconfianza a cualquier
negociación que se haga con la
centroizquierda con la derecha pero esas
negociaciones van a ser necesarias
porque el gobierno no tiene mayoría no
entonces creo que es ahí hay un trabajo
que hacer con de dar a entender de que
es necesario lograr estos amplios
acuerdos pues porque hay muchos sectores
que son más politizados más movilizados
que tienen un rechazo total al
establecimiento político de los últimos
criterios no quieren ver negociar ahí y
esa relación creo que va a ser una de
las más más complejas isabel oeste toca
el punto justamente que quería comenzar
por tocar aquí en este debate y es
gobernar chile sin mayoría en el
congreso esto que dificultades va a
implicar en el camino en el desarrollo
de las propuestas y de las ideas y este
plan de cambio que tiene el presidente
boris cuál es el análisis que usted hace
bueno creo que la señal lo que ha dicho
el gobierno que quieren hacer es un gran
trabajo pre legislativo no como de
reconocer que el gobierno anterior es
parte del problema era que se ingresaba
en los proyectos de ley al congreso
tiene acuerdos previos y entonces ahí
moría entonces que hay que hacer un
trabajo con los partidos pero también
con sectores más amplios en temas de
reforma tributaria hay que hablar antes
con los empresarios y con otros actores
para llegar con un acuerdo político más
amplio
creo que conciencia de que es posible
que no se logre todo que la reforma
tributaria que está pensada para
recaudar 5 puntos del pib posiblemente
recoge menos o que haya que hacerla en
etapas entonces ya hay cierta conciencia
de ello pero pero va a requerir mucha
negociación
hoy en día chile también tiene un
sistema un congreso muy fragmentado hay
más partidos que nunca y también hay
muchos partidos que tienen poca
disciplina interna no entonces los
últimos años lo que ocurre también es
que se termina negociando con
legisladores individuales que están más
dispuestos tal vez a apoyar una agenda
de gobierno y eso bueno evidentemente
hace que la negociación sea costosa pero
hay algunos sectores dentro de la
centroderecha que serían como algunos
votos que se necesitan que creo que
pueden estar dispuestos a apoyar algunas
de las reformas por la tienden que son
necesarias
lucia lo que puede uno también ver desde
fuera de chile en otros países de
américa latina y teniendo en cuenta la
historia que ha tenido chile y el
gobierno reciente que terminó con
sebastián piñera es que tal vez el
presidente boris llega a formar una
forma distinta de relacionarse con los
ciudadanos chilenos sebastián piñera
representada esa clase
adinerada dueños de empresas del sector
empresarial chileno que es un porcentaje
muy pequeño de la población y tal vez
michelle bachelet representaba a ese
sector de la sociedad chilena que fue
víctima de algunos abusos por parte de
la de la dictadura y que reivindicaba
esos derechos
una vez terminó el gobierno de pinochet
que representa ahora gabriel boric
retomó ese ese punto que ustedes
mencionaban de un cambio generacional
pero como es ese relacionamiento entre
boris y el ciudadano chileno del común
que lo ha cautivado
es muy interesante esa pregunta porque
en gran medida el éxito en la segunda
vuelta se debe de boris en que se debe a
una estrategia comunicacional muy bien
diseñada y pensada
basada en un contacto de cercanía donde
en este caso la que es ahora ministra
del interior
sitges
acerco casa por casa sobre todo en la
zona del norte donde era un punto de
pivote para parar las elecciones y se
terminó
ganando y si es una estrategia basada en
cercanía basada en desestructurar las
lógicas protocolares de
formalidad es muy millennial pensemos
que además de él instagram y en twitter
del presidente tenemos el instagram y el
twitter de su perro brownie que hay
claramente y un mensaje que de buscar
cercanía con jóvenes que probablemente
vayan a votar que ahora no puedan
hacerlo pero que vayan a votar en las
próximas elecciones
también hay una lógica ahí detrás de
marketing en el que se sabe que muchos
padres toman las decisiones en función
de lo que los hijos les dicen el
contacto con los niños los niños como el
futuro del país también forma parte de
la estrategia comunicacional así que
creo que igual hay efectos en la
estrategia comunicacional que está
implementando ahora es que todavía no
vamos a poder vislumbrar si no es
evidente estarán a ver los resultados
probablemente en un futuro intermedio
veíamos haciendo algún barrido por los
medios de comunicación chilenos el día
de hoy veíamos que algunas personas han
comenzado a hacer turismo en un sector
del centro de la capital que es la calle
donde vivían gabriel boric que es un
barrio completamente normal del centro
antiguo de la ciudad de santiago y que
ahora se ha vuelto un punto de visita
obligada para muchas personas allí en la
capital chilena cosa que no sucedía con
un presidente como por ejemplo sebastián
piñera que vive en otro sector muy
distinto y que era un poco más apartado
del centro urbano de la capital puntos
que empiezan a cambiar con este cambio
del gobierno isabel su opinión sobre
esta cercanía con el pueblo esta
percepción diferente que hay por parte
de los chilenos en torno a su nuevo
presidente
sí bueno efectivamente creo que un tema
generacional o sea de relaciones más
horizontales es alguien que bueno se ha
ido acostumbrando pero que en general
inicialmente se notaba muy incómodo y
rechazó lo más que pudo el tema de las
escoltas por ejemplo no
y entonces tiene una relación más
cercana hasta yo diría hasta que fue
electo hasta hace poquito manejaba en su
cuenta de twitter comentaba con o sea
una relación muy bueno un hombre de 36
años
común y corriente en el sentido y creo
que eso se percibe por la ciudadanía o
sea el lugar donde va y como dice estuvo
en su barrio pero también en el lugar
que estuvo trabajando antes de asumir lo
que se llamaba la moneda chica siempre
había gente esperando lo muchos niños
personas mayores también que creo que
ven como no sea un nieto o algo así y
entonces hay mucho interés por conocer
por por saludarlo y algo que marcaba la
diferencia es que en general se da el
tiempo de saludar que muchas veces se
sale del protocolo entonces refuerza esa
relación saludo a sus vecinos y claro y
además da señales como la que
mencionabas tú que él decidió él se tuvo
que cambiar del departamento donde vivía
porque no cumplían con las condiciones
de seguridad y decidieron irse a un
barrio tradicional del centro de
santiago en general todos los
presidentes en el sector más cómodo
entonces eso también una señal de que no
se quisiera vivir cerca de que no me
quiero distancia
de
del ciudadano más común o bien con todas
las diferencias que puede tener un
presidente no pero hay algo creo que es
su personalidad hasta de su forma de ser
y eso en la edad que
genera cierta incomodidad con esta
instancia y él busca romperla como puede
dentro de lo posible evidentemente no
puede deshacerse del escolta pero sí
pero si todavía lo vemos que va a
comprar y a veces se comenta lo corneó
ciudadano común y corriente como
cualquier persona del común isabel lucía
quiero que hablemos de algunos de los
temas importantes de la agenda doméstica
de los temas importantes al interior de
chile me llama la atención la situación
con la región de la araucanía sabemos el
conflicto que hay allí histórico con las
comunidades mapuches el presidente
sebastián piñera decretó el estado de
excepción y militarizó buena parte de
esa zona con allí ha habido fuertes
conflictos y choques a lo largo de los
últimos años en posición de boris en
torno a esto él dice que no va a renovar
ese estado de excepción y que opta por
el diálogo pero que tanto margen de
diálogo allí en la región de la
araucanía y también creo que podemos
poner sobre la mesa el conflicto que hay
en el norte por el tema de los migrantes
si no estoy mal en la región de iquique
en el norte isabel comienzo por usted
sin bueno creo que hay una señal
importante de parte del gobierno de
hacer de bueno de ambos temas prioridad
hoy día en su primer lunes en el cargo
de la ministra
interior y junto a otros ministros o
esta semana vayan a viajar al sur
entonces ya de inicio hay una señal de
darle una prioridad y de sentarse con
actores que yo creo que no
luego que no hasta ahora no se han
sentado no
de bueno la señal es ciertamente de
desmilitarizar y de abrir este diálogo
hay sectores más radicalizados que
difícilmente quieran dialogar pero se
puede construir posiblemente una mayoría
y ver y ver soluciones y esto va creo
que muy de la mano de lo que ocurre en
el proceso constituyente donde buena
parte gracias a los escaños reservados
que representan los pueblos indígenas se
está avanzando mucho en una agenda
plurinacional de
reconocimiento de los pueblos
originarios no entonces
creo que
buscar soluciones nuevas el tema de la
tierra sigue siendo un conflicto central
y en el sur en particular es con colas
forestales que se han instalado en esa
zona sí pero me parece que hay una señal
importante de prioridad política y de
buscar soluciones que no se han
planteado hasta ahora lucirá su opinión
en torno a este tema estos temas
prioritarios de la agenda la situación
de la araucanía en la región de chicas
también y de todas maneras y bueno
tomando un poco el planteamiento que
hace isabel de como el proceso
constituyente con el reconocimiento de
los pueblos originarios y sus escaños
reservados a la hora de diseñar esta
nueva constitución también se nota en
este cambio discursivo porque hoy por
ejemplo cuando el presidente tuvo su
primera ronda de prensa manifestando un
poco cuáles eran los pasos que se iban a
seguir él en lugar de hacer referencia a
la región de la araucanía dijo el
wallmapu y lo mismo hizo la ministra del
interior el one mapu es el nombre
mapuche y esto ya generó una reacción en
ciertos representantes y en
diputados o alcaldes de la zona
partidos más conservadores que hicieron
un llamado a corregir y volver a usar la
palabra araucanía mostrando también una
resistencia que es evidente que existe
en la zona y un rechazo que es ha sido
el caldo de cultivo de este conflicto en
todo caso ha dicho expresamente el
presidente que se iba a dialogar con sus
víctimas de delitos que se iba a
dialogar con
forestales que se iba a dialogar con
organizaciones que están buscando y
haciendo reivindicaciones etcétera pero
creo que hay un punto de discusión más
importante que tiene que ver cómo se ha
aplicado y por qué se ha creado la ley
antiterrorista en chile que ha dado
lugar y anualmente da lugar a que chile
sea sancionado en la corte
interamericana de derechos humanos por
un uso excesivo de sanciones represión
etcétera de esta ley que termina
violando los derechos humanos esa es una
pregunta que evidentemente esta
administración va a poner sobre la mesa
y un cuestionamiento de base que
qué está haciendo la sociedad chilena
bueno
vamos llegando ya a la recta final del
programa lucía pasó a preguntarle por el
tema económico a expectativa cómo hacer
esa relación entre el presidente y el
sector del empresariado en el sector
agrícola chile también ha tenido que
vivir en unos años de sequía
muy pronunciados que ha afectado
seriamente la producción allí en este en
este país incluso ha habido pocas
precipitaciones y un gran déficit de
agua nieve que eso afecta a los cultivos
en algunas regiones del país y el tema
económico prima también porque estamos
saliendo en cierta forma de la crisis
que generó la pandemia de kobe 19 lucía
su opinión en torno a esta relación con
el empresariado
y
la evaluación económica todavía por lo
que entiendo falta ser de hecho se le
entrevistó a la presidenta del banco
central en el momento de tomar posición
en la moneda el viernes y aviso que
estaban preparando un informe que iba a
ser entregado a finales de este mes para
poder establecer un plan de acción de
ahí en adelante por lo demás por lo que
tengo entendido este primer año
más allá del conflicto o sea los
distintos conflictos que la guerra entre
ucrania y en rusia ha generado que ha
generado desabastecimiento en ciertas
materias primas para chile igual se
prevé un crecimiento luego de estos años
de pandemia la relación con la élite y
como tú bien dices
que la élite económica implica múltiples
carisma aristas que tienen que ver desde
cuál es el rol de las pequeñas y
medianas empresas versus cuál es el rol
y la lógica hacer para llevarse a cabo
con un empresariado o un sector más
monopolístico creo que todavía ahí nos
queda pendiente en ciertas medidas
claves y veremos como son adoptadas
isabel un tema interesante ver cómo va a
ser el relacionamiento de chile con la
región con américa latina y también con
países clave como por ejemplo estados
unidos país con que ha tenido siempre
una relación muy estrecha muchos lo
califican con como que esto va a ser un
gobierno que representa una izquierda un
poco más cosmopolita porque
claramente el presidente boris ha
comenzado desde ya a defender ciertos
valores occidentales por ejemplo rechazo
la invasión de rusia al territorio
ucraniano ha rechazado algunas
violaciones de derechos humanos en
venezuela y en nicaragua y eso muestra
una tendencia en que se desmarca un poco
de esa izquierda que veníamos viendo en
américa latina' como ustedes el
relacionamiento del país con el resto de
la región y con esas divisiones
políticas que hay porque además que dos
países claves de la región van a elegir
presidente y tienen relación estrecha
con chile y son brasil
sí efectivamente creo que bonita está
reflejando una nueva izquierda en la
izquierda latinoamericana ha tenido
relaciones siempre complejas con
bueno en parte con jugó pero más
recientemente con venezuela hay sectores
que todavía
se niegan a hablar abiertamente en una
dictadura en nicaragua no y gabriel
boric desde el día 12 y esto salió en
casi todos los debates durante la
campaña no tiene problema en hablar de
que esos son regímenes dictatoriales que
violan los derechos humanos y que su
utilidad está ahí e independiente del
signo político no lo mismo como
mencionaba el día 1 condenó la invasión
rusa y ucrania y eso marca una
diferencia a los derechos humanos en
general son un pilar de el gobierno en
general y de su política exterior en
particular es una política exterior que
busca ser moderna como con el centro de
los derechos humanos pero una política
feminista también sí muy orientada hacia
a combatir el cambio climático y
reposicionar a chile en los espacios
multilaterales entornos en torno a estos
temas no ya y
claro hay afinidad comentaba que ayer
habló por ejemplo una hora con el primer
ministro canadiense contras título no
haya y hay ciertas afinidades en el
estilo y agenda claro
y como menciona claro también sectores
de izquierdas a petro de hecho fue
invitado al hábil cambio de banco y sin
tener ningún cargo oficial no como un
invitado personal del presidente
entonces hay también una
intención de establecer estas redes a
nivel latinoamericano
pero con estos valores centrales lucía
ya nos acercamos a la recta final del
programa su opinión en torno a la
política exterior hacia dónde se
dirigirá a chile bajo el mando de
porsche
de todas maneras hay que pensar en
quienes estuvieron ausentes en la toma
de posición de representantes de
nicaragua y de venezuela eso muestra
claramente la idea que estaba
transmitiendo isabel de como además
discursivamente el presidente hizo
énfasis en que atacaran se perseguirán
se irá en contra de toda violación de
los derechos humanos venga del color
político que venga ahí fue expreso y
también figuras pensemos en las
felicitaciones que le hicieron desde la
unión europea hay una búsqueda también
de cercanía pese a que dentro de la
región su primera visita va a ser
argentina y probablemente en brasil haya
un cambio de color político en las
próximas elecciones y eso insiste una
cercanía pero mis apuestas serían por un
refuerzo de diálogo una fortalecimiento
con la unión europea que quizás siempre
había estado
un poquito más aislada pero la unión
europea se está dando cuenta también
importante de reforzar discursos y
liderazgos democráticos porque en los
peligros que han significado trump en
eeuu ó bolsonaro en brasil generan
colapsos y conflictos a la hora de
relaciones internacionales que es
importante está prestarles atención
porque la forma de hacer política y
reivindicar la democracia es clave si
queremos estar en un mundo más pacífico
además que el presidente dé por hecho y
lo ha dicho que algunos de los países
europeos particularmente los
escandinavos son su referente en cuanto
a ese sistema de bienestar ese ambicioso
sistema de bienestar que quiere
instaurar allí en chile pues a lucia y a
isabelle les agradezco por haber estado
con nosotros en el programa por haber
analizado estos diferentes puntos que
llaman la atención de este nuevo
gobierno que toma el liderazgo allí en
chile en este país suramericano esta
historia apenas está comenzando vamos a
estar allí siguiendo lo que suceda en
chile para irlo analizando aquí en el
debate de france 24 ustedes muchas
gracias por la sintonía y pueden seguir
con france 24
[Música]